歡迎收看趙華 歡迎收看
我是趙華 今天終於打腳了
好 當然你當我幹嘛 打腳
對 確實打腳
因為昨天我們還在討論
因為昨天有下跌第一天
沒錯 但今天盤中有跌到
大概一千點 開盤就一千點
開盤啦 開盤就一千點
說實話有一點嚇一跳
怎麼搞的說來就來
沒錯
可是大家期待了打腳
終於開始在打了
不知道打完了沒
但是確實
你這一次急拉過程
大家一直在問說有沒有
第二次可以買的機會
所以這一次出現了
那我們等置疊
我覺得應該還是可以去好好把握一下
因為一波的V轉
好多人都想說
好像反彈那麼快
我沒有辦法上車
但是市場就這麼有趣
像昨天晚上費辦就跌了五個百分點
沒錯
然後講的事情
你會覺得
之前不是就知道嗎
對啊
他們講說AI有相關
有九家大公司的隱藏的負債
有三兆美元
那現在
這個市場利率一直往上飆的話
對
這些債務將來就會爆破這樣子
因為會貴嘛
對
講得那麼可怕
可是其實今天台股
還算是有強力的支撐
因為他下面拉了一支下影線
所以
我們來看一下
到底所謂的直立率
標這件事情
為什麼跟AR聯在一起
等一下會簡單的跟大家聊一下
再來的話不要忘記一件事情
每一次在上漲
就說我們台股好多的元件
在漲價 下跌就忘了嗎
沒吧 漲價還還是在發
所以等一下會講的是公率元件
沒錯 這個我們等一下
來幫大家好好瞭解一下
這個我們先來快速的瞄一下
就是又有鬼故事了
那目前來說
左邊這邊就是川普
直接發佈了一張地圖
什麼地圖
就是呢 河母在海峽
就是美國的新領土
其實就一個重點
那個重點就是
美英現在是談不攏的
然後目前已經進入
下一個世代了
這個世代就是呢
我們可能也不會攻擊了
但是呢 就會拖在這裡
但是由於像上漲
大家就是有通膨壓力
同樣的還是看來
對經濟市場有老亂
那不過呢
昨天就是有一些
美債之一的飆升
跟這一個新聞
這個新聞就是包含了9家
美國的9大家
就是什麼伯通那些全部加進來
除了傳統的
我們在提的四大CSP大廠之外
周邊也都有加起來AMD等等
這些加進來之後
它與相關AI的表外承諾
已經達到了三兆美元
那這個三兆美元
是不會放在它的財報裡面的
不會放在資產
它不會放在資產負債表
付出了裡面包含了
就是對於未來
有幾家啦 譬如說可能像是
就四大家嘛 裡面有說他買能源
那已經買到2054年了
那這些東西呢
因為都還沒有開始算
所以都不用列進來
但實際上他們簽的那個約呢
是不管你AI發展好還是不好
你未來就是一定要付這筆簽
好 未開始的租約
但已經給人家簽了
是的 而且簽就是簽很長
然後簽的金額又很大
那目前來說呢
整個這個是表內的
表內的負債2480
長期負債有3560億
那表外的這邊就有9000億
那這裡 total會有1.5兆
所以直接加一加
弄一弄就大概3兆左右
美元喔
夠承諾
是的
就是像可能揮達要跟
台積電跟美光
或者說跟記憶體廠
要簽訂未來的長約
我們常常有聽到
美光簽長約
未來營收有保障
對不對
那這些錢要誰付
就是這一些大老傅
好
再搭配前一陣子
大家講他的自由現金流
已經轉付了
是的 所以可能很多要付出
學費的錢將來是要借錢來給的
沒錯 他們沒有特別拿出來講的
這個金額已經大大的
大家的超過大家想像空間了
對 所以目前這個
整個AI的軍備競賽
如火如荼
如火如荼 那大家就覺得
這個是不是就要崩盤啦
泡沫啦 付不出來啦
不過目前我們台灣看起來
還處在一個你借就借吧
反正你單要給我啦
反正我現在有拿到訂單的
一個情況
只有一個恐怖平衡的狀態
沒錯
那我這邊幫他
快速解釋一下
為什麼他們
難道這一些
CEO會不知道
錢燒成這樣子
不會擔心嗎
他們能夠做到
這個大公司的CEO
可是他們現在其實更在意的是
未來誰是AI的領頭央
只要我能拿到霸主的地位
這些錢我都賺得回來
邏輯就是這樣
所以他們現在
頭洗下去了
你洗到一半
你要泡泡洗乾淨
所以他們現在洗到一半
頭都還是泡泡
那你只能一直向下洗
那向下洗大家就要砸錢嘛
所以砸到未來
一定有一天那個龍頭會出現
所以現在大家
至少這四大家都想當龍頭
他不在意現在我會不會虧錢
對 所以這場戲應該
還要再看一陣子
那我覺得對於台廠來講
應該就是好事
是你們搶吧
對
你們搶
反正都要跟我們要
OK 好 再來呢
美在水綠最近
哇 這個走得非常
三十年級創下了
三十年級的美債創下了一個十九年來的新高
是 最利率
沒錯 那這個直率拉起來呢
又跟這個之前修正的時候
迎來的一個話題是一樣的
就是科技股的估值修正
跟科技股 跟股市的這個資金排體效應
而且現在大家也擔心啊
這個好像很久沒人提了
美國的財政赤字
它不停的發新環節
是 這個新的會越來越貴哦
還要 沒錯
後來要還的錢跟剛剛其實不是一樣
所以其實要還不完
我們單看這個數據
我覺得美國不太可能升息
雖然合理通膨要抗通膨 要升息
可是如果你再繼續升息
這個數字只會越來越高
對 那現在有一些資金的幾對效應
所以帶動它的值益率去拉高
那你這個時候我覺得升息的機率
會降得更低
對 那為什麼
整個還是很重要
因為美債值益率
是一個全球資產定價的定毛持之一
那再來對科技股的影響
就是我今天只要防災美債
美國又不會倒
對 我就領個快6%的利息
對 年化嘛
那可是呢 我這個買股票
哇 我7月如果跌 這樣跌個40%
那我乾脆把錢都
一部分的資金拿來放美債
反正這是無風險的報酬嘛
所以到時候可能AI也
即便有AI發展還是會比較辛苦
好 剛剛講到一些
可能大家關注的一些總經力空
我們來講一些產業力多
Cowars爆單外易
那台積電啦 又是台積電
所以目前看起來
我們的產業面這一塊
應該是還是沒什麼問題的
所以這也代表說
像今天為什麼一開盤
有受到鎂骨影響殺下去
那後來我們也隨即有拉一個腳
就是回到我們的基本面
或是我們的接單狀況
是 還是受益的啦
沒錯 我們來看一下
AI需求擴大
GPU加ASIC同步放量
Cowars不能只在靠AMD
Google AMD這一些
都同步去擴大晶片的佈局
那再來呢
後段的瓶頸浮現了
前段出很快
但是後段的封裝跟不上
所以英特爾馬來西亞廠呢
會協力去做支援
那再來另外一個就是
CoAWs會成為新的護城河
相關的不能只看製程
還有GPU ASIC HBM先進封裝
不知道這基本上就一條龍
所以這一些都是什麼
這些都是未來選股票的這個邏輯
那從CoAWs的擴產到先進
到封裝的設備
到測試的設備
到一些探診卡
然後到這個ABF載板材料
基本上這就是什麼
這就是全股池
對 比較簡單一點的邏輯是這樣
那這個至少還是可以證明啦
就是我們不曉得泡沫什麼時候會結束
但至少就目前這幾
這一兩年的狀況來看
台積電的co-works相關的題材
應該都還是會是一個非常好的狀況
給大家一點信心
就是沒想到連Intel對不對
有加入跟台積電的合作
沒錯
可是台積電確實近期的股價
表現比較沒有到大跌
然後就是一個平穩的狀態
然後成交量是大幅度的萎縮的
那大幅度萎縮過程中
今天跌破了一個小平台
就2350
所以接下來要守好的平台呢
就是這個低點
這個低點在2300
那目前來說都還是一個橫向震盪
所以大家不要說
他今天破季線
今天四條均線全破怎麼辦
他緩到我沒有留意到
他今天破季線
沒有錯
對
所以他不用太緊張
因為他是區間震盪
所以區間震盪
相信整理的時候
均線不會給支撐或壓力的效果
所以大家觀察的就是
我反彈這高點的夢過
也就是說你季線站回來
你也不用太開心
你2450突破我們再開心
那你真的要緊張
前低跌破
再來緊張就好了
不過以台電來說
出現這樣的情況的時候
你通常視為是蠻一點
以台電那麼穩定的
獲利成長狀況來說
然後買了就不要一直看它
因為每天看沒什麼意思
它就長這樣
長得非常的精闢
對 你如果買還機電視
可以刪掉APP的
不然就是一個禮拜載回來一次
再來看到大盤的部分
大盤我們昨天說到
這一波行情嚴重MV5
那昨天MV5跌破
要進行注意可能就是整理的狀態
所以今天繼續整理
剛好今天越結算
所以整理幅度要稍微
有些超買超賣的狀態
那不管怎麼樣
我們今天記得
這時日均線跟季線
原本站上的呢
又這個德爾富斯了
所以又跌破了
那跌破我們昨天跟大家說
你這一個大量的高低點
可以去留意一下會不會給支撐
那這個地方跌破
所以我們要看的就是這裡
這個地方呢
在這個4300
4400左右
上下大概加100點
就是這個小區間
那這個小區間呢
後面還有一個什麼
還有一個月線
所以這也會有個雙重的支撐
我想問我看今天月線
好像變下完了
那如果這樣會不會支撐變弱
會
基本上下彎不算支撐
但是這幾天扣底下來
它是有機會彎上來的
所以我覺得這邊觀察一下
大量的低點能不能連同月線
給一個支撐的狀態
雖然說不是說拉下影線
就是買點嗎
對 雖然今天拉下影線
可是今天的下影線
我覺得它的力道比較薄弱
如果今天它是紅色的
長這樣
收回開盤架
它就很兇
確實是很漂亮
因為整個禮儀拉1000點
可是今天這樣子就是
只能知道底部回來的時候
是有人願意去買的
可是你說買到變紙碟嗎
那我覺得可能要在一兩天的訊號
所以明天如果能夠好一點
結算完 結算壓行情
結算完 如果明天跟紅K
吃掉今天的黑K
那我覺得基本上差不多
就不錯囉
就不錯囉 就可以視為買點囉
那接下來要挑戰的就是
我們先回武日軍
再來挑戰前高
前高過 那這就是個大恩之情
這就是大家想要的第二隻腳
對 只是有點長短腳
對 長短腳還可以吧
不錯啊 台灣腳比較好
因為修正幅度不大
但目前今天這根
還沒有止跌訊號
我覺得可以再看個一兩天
好吧
對 那再來貴買也是一樣
碰季線壓下來
然後也是來到這個
我們昨天有說
這邊也是貴買大量的低點
然後有守住
那有守住這邊也碰月線
所以也還不錯
但跟大盤一樣
我覺得都是
有人願意接
但還沒有接到
讓它變成是止跌的
K-Bump訊號出現
所以我覺得上市跟上櫃都一樣
同步觀察一下
後面如果禮拜四禮拜五有反彈
如果能夠站回五率均線
這個站回來
那我覺得就差不多了
應該就可以去找一些好股票來看一下
有沒有低血的機會了
所以我覺得這一波回落
大家不用太緊張
是
那我覺得這一波回落的體感
也不會到
雖然不好啦
但是也沒有跟之前那樣相比的
體感這麼差
像今天上檔加速還算多的
還是不錯的
所以我覺得大家就不用太恐慌
那也要保持一些信心
等指液訊號出現
再來重新討好的去有沒有一些股票可以賣
送暖的感覺
是的
所以呢
下一段節目回來的話
我們要聊的叫做公立元件
他們是有所謂的標股基因
那現在可以看得出來
法人大戶投信
有稍微佈局
在所謂的被動元件上面
公立元件有沒有呢
其實也有零星級檔是有的
那有這樣的標股基因
又看到我們看到
疫法半導體發出了漲價
8月下旬要開始漲價了
所以能不能夠在這波回檔
重新啟動上工的時候
漲價概念股可以回來
有興趣的朋友
可以掃一下艾倫說的QR code
明天早上一樣會發送
公率元件的藏報圖給大家
那等一下我們就來聊
公率元件到底看好哪些股票
好 來吧
最近的這個備用元件
上個禮拜稍微反彈一下
那又走路了兩三天
今天被動算蠻厲害的
當然國劇還好啦
可是像什麼
新商店
那個誰
那個日電帽
金山店這些都漲停板
那其實早上的時候
這個強帽等人
也都是開高的
土被動本來今天還不錯
但後來只剩被動
對沒錯
所以呢我們
剛剛我看一下形態
我覺得還可以
那當然這兩天又大概有一個題材
就是因為要漲價
是 這個公立元件
第三波半導體啦
第三波漲價來了
台賞10月要再漲15%
漲價時成
這邊都幫他準備好了
這個2026年10月的時候
因為他們算後面才漲的
所以到明年搞不好漲價幅度
還可以期待
是的 那目前來說
像強茂啊 台辦
這兩個比較具代表性
然後德維尼克森等等的
基本上都是對於他們的產品
要做一個調漲的狀態
那為什麼要漲價呢
首先第一個 金上游
對 跟他講一下
像上游的合金這一類的
對
他們也算是公綠半導體
他們是元件類的
是
那個
上面的金元類的
對
那導線架還有封裝材料
同步的走壓
再來供給呢
如果是單純因為要
轉嫁成本的去調漲
那我覺得這個吸引力
稍微低一點點
但你可以發現就是
其實需求是很大
因為供給是供不完的
那我覺得這個就非常有吸引力
目前部分成交的交期
拉長到了52週
那另外呢 整個機櫃公率往800服務去做賣進
所以帶動了使用量去增加
也就是說它其實不單純只是因為AI通膨
而是說它的需求確實也是不錯的
蠻重要的這一點
沒錯 所以這邊是後續可以去注意的其中一個大題材
那當然這個在7月6月崩盤之前
公率元件已經拉一大段了
那時候講得很誇張
我們全市場都在缺貨
沒錯 但也有人出來說沒有那麼誇張
但還還漲價跟國外大廠已經發出漲價還是確定的
是的
所以我覺得這個以漲價題材來講
還是可以稍微注意一下
那這邊基本上都是所謂的公率元件類的
那其實還有很多
包含像是電源管理IC
比如說那個什麼C-KY
立志啊這個都歸類在裡面
那因為像風車還有什麼
撿米ky
對然後剛提到吸金原廠
其實這個都是歸類在公率半導體裡面
不過呢如果以
元件類漲價題材來講
那確實是這一些比較主流一點點
那今天可以注意到
全部都撐之不齊
還行啦
就是像今天的盤面
你說疊也疊沒有太多
長也還好這樣子的一個形式
沒有錯
所以這個是一些概念股
給大家做參考
那裡面我們當然就要講一些
可能比較代表性的人物了
首先第一個就台辦
代表性的人物
好 強貌台辦是一組的
我們講台辦
就常常連在一起這樣子
等一下有強貌物的
是...
第三波長這樣
10月要開跑了
對非合約的客戶要漲價10到15%
那整個算力伺服器的效率非常嚴格
所以對於他們的整個高規格的公率元件來講
是貴 然後量又大
那再來呢 目前第二季的EPS已經年增
上半年的EPS年增
半年爆出來了 年增138%
所以有沒有賺錢 有啦
還有在努力賺錢
那只不過
台辦跟強貿過往的股信是真的不太好
對啊
對 但至少前面那一波走勢還算拉得乾脆
那這一波修正幅度也很大
這個都是腰斬再下來
那你可以注意到腰斬下來之後
這裡的行情就呈現了一個橫向震盪
可是它有多頭
它反彈的不太乾脆
是 而且它反彈的力道稍微薄弱一點點
對 跟被動元件這一波有一點點相似
那我們這邊就稍微注意一下
這個在高檔回落的過程中
其實它還算相對強勢一點點
因為前面漲得少
所以跌也可能也比較輕
那跌比較輕
後面如果要做一個資金族群的輪動
我覺得是可以去留意一些相關地位階
這可能就跟宣估有關
跟族群沒有關
對 那這個公率元件
是一個相對位階比較低的
那這邊已經拉出一個N字型
這兩天有在放量
那唯一比較尷尬
人家在進攻的時候遇到大盤整理
對
就可能情緒沒這麼激情
前面沒跟別人攻
這個要攻了大盤回檔
對 因為可能他漲價要漲在大盤
新聞出來 出在大盤要回落的時候
那不過我覺得OK
因為他這邊也願意去有一個新高
現在就季線突破 這兩天開始放量
只要這兩個大量的高點
都去共同做突破 站回季線
其實我覺得這個行情後續還可以注意一下
有沒有去往前高做靠攏的一個機會
那這個位階購低
我覺得停順點也好抓
這邊就可以視為停順
那你如果要拉比較遠就要拉到前低
但我覺得這有點太遠
所以可能這一根紅K
去做跌破就可以做一個停順的動作
那就看嘛 你這邊
已經盤整很久都沒有跌破嘛
所以跌破就走 我覺得OK
那如果盤整後慢慢的還電高
那一個賺賠比的邏輯來看應該還不錯
好 畢竟在下跌之前
公園一切我也聽到很多好消息
難道好消息就不見了嗎
沒有 所以用風險報酬比來幫大家抓
是 但也要提醒前面套樓的人確實
確實多 蠻多的
那再來另外一個
提到了 牆帽
他走得好整齊喔
是的 他走成一排牙齒
沒錯 所以整個的狀態來講
都是一個盤整的狀態
那目前盤整當然就是等一個盤整突破
那突破要突破什麼
一樣這兩天都有在挑戰
像昨天其實氣勢也很好
但是碰前高 那量有放大
可是沒有過
沒有過就變壓力了
所以對啊 沒有過就壓力
昨天買的也套牢了
你們技術型態好狠喔
沒有辦法
對啊 所以它其實要轉很快
那不過我們就是等這個平台突破
那這個平台剛好有兩個大量
所以這個平台突破
基本上季線也就應該要過了
那就會相行整理又站回季線
那我覺得這個行情
就有機會迎來一波往前高
去做靠近的一個反台行情
所以我覺得這個都是值得
如果有耐心的這邊可以蹲看看
然後聽說你都很好抓
前低跌破就記得走
對 所以我覺得這邊都有一些
可以去蹲看看的樣子
再來看到立正
立正 還有誰
立正
OK 好
比較少聊到他
沒錯 但為什麼會選他
因為我看一下
公立元件半導體裡面
他有基本上只有他
是站上機線的
對 你看
台辦強方沒站上
傅鼎也沒站上
就是等於大家很關注那一些
反而形態上要比較辛苦
是
他反而在默默之中在機線上
對 他應該是說
他反彈的過程比較快站回機線
對 那比較快站回機線的過程中
其實他基本面也還可以
五年新高
然後年增率達81%
所以是有在好轉的
當然我覺得如果是以最直接來講的話
應該就前面那兩位
可是如果看形態來講的話
那就立正反而
掃出在季線之上的公立元件
我們用形態也偶爾會發現
好奇妙 搞不好就變得領頭強勢
而且他前面其實那一段的延續性比較好
如果你大家回去看技術面的話
當然來到這個地方
我們先注意的是他在季線之上
可是今天這個大量位置
就會是短線能夠站上再縮
再要不要考慮介入的
因為這邊一個頭
來到這個地方
全部都是壓力區
那壓力區今天想要挑戰
行情不好就失敗
那也就是說呢
你現在想要介入
我們就把這個消化過去
N字型能夠確立的時候
那剛好也是一個大底部的確立
那我覺得到時候再來重新去做操作就可以
所以呢
季線之上
大概只有他
那可是型態要更好
那我們高點要做突破
那等到做突破再來做介入
其實我覺得不會太遲
對
所以這邊給大家觀察一下
這幾檔
三黨這個相關的公立元件的個股
好 那傅鼎長的是像臺辦強帽嗎
長得像強帽
因為我想傅鼎應該蠻多三會
我在上面
對 那個也基本上也是長這樣
就是也都是在這邊很旁邊
好 傅鼎長的像這樣
對 所以我覺得那個也可以看
但我想說兩黨指標股之外
就加一個形態好看的
給他做參考
有時候也要來一點新鮮貨
忽然說實話 公立元件的族群不大
講來講去就那幾檔
但是希望藉由教大家
現在有一些指標性的股票
至少以風險報酬比來抓
不會太高
破了前面的低點
你就可能趕快出去
但如果突破了呢
那也許上面他有標股金
就會在網上
好 需要今天節目
所有的圖卡資料的話一樣
歡迎訂閱一下
趙華艾倫說的YouTube頻道
我們會把所有的資料
免費放在首頁進來的天文欄
那廣告回來呢
有大來賓要上場了
今天很用心
因為他要告訴大家
反彈到這邊
有人已經多頭型態完成了
而且蓄勢待發
有人還在做一個空頭的型態
今天會有隨堂考
歡迎大家留下來考試了
歡迎回到趙華
好 你說
我們今天要好好來幫大家聊
就是談到這邊不是回檔了嗎
對呀
其實是不是滿地都是機會
哦唷
素杀
哦這個等一下來賓會說
為什麼要賊給來賓
就給來賓發揮啊
因為以技術形態來說
有時候反而是
你一波彈上去
找不到什麼切入點
沒錯
可是一旦回檔切入點就變得很多了
我們現在歡迎今天來賓
因為大家都非常的喜歡他
也非常的熟悉
我也很喜歡不要喬
好今天來的是我們的
K線之神朱家恆
朱老師
大家好大家好大家好
我們來聊一下
因為之前一直在談嘛
台股要不要打腳啊什麼的
好像真的打了
打了反而是好事喔
那今天要來教我們什麼呢
因為打了就可能出現
所謂的轉折對不對
如果懂轉折的人
其實上面下來也能轉
下面上去也能轉
怎麼那麼厲害啊
對啊
那我也加入你們的門派了
今天二對一
主老師先幫我們看這個多頭趨勢
我們最後給一個問
好 這個我們看我們的大盤
那昨天是不是有轉折了
他上去下來了嘛
那這個就轉折了
所以昨天出現轉折
昨天出現轉折
那如果你是下面轉折買的
那上面呢 要賣了嘛
只要你出現轉折
如果你下面買這個強反彈
那你現在跌你就賣掉了
就這麼一例嗎
什麼意思啊
如果你做空也看
你出現轉折空
然後這邊出現轉折就補
你這邊空
這邊補
這邊空
這邊補嘛
就這樣子
做空嘛
做空
那你搶反彈
當然在下面搶嘛
那下面是不是一個轉折
那這裡是不是一個轉折
所以你在轉折的地方買
在轉折的地方買就結束了
那我們的大盤呢
再來看趨勢
我們的大盤在反彈的時候
已經過了這個前高了
對
那現在它不是空頭
也不是多頭
它有頭頭高
這邊是底底
所以還差了一個底底高
那這邊我們就再等這個
又是等一個轉折
那這個轉折如果一出現
它就變成多頭了
那多頭是做多啊
所以就可以做多了
如果下次轉折
因為我們做股票計幅分醫人
不是在說明天我要做
明天出現轉折我才做
你沒有出現
也許還會再下來
那下來這邊
也是會看到一個轉折
如果符合這樣子的話
它也是一個多頭架構
所以我們的大盤基本上來講
現在應該算是強勢反彈之後
就在等第二隻腳了
那第二隻腳的先結條件
要先回來
如果你這邊不回來
就沒有第二隻腳
所以在沒有回來的時候
大家都講說
他不會回來
每次股票也是
連續漲五六天
大家都都不會回來了
實際上歷史證明嗎
他一定會回來
好 那我們現在等到回來
那現在就在等上漲
等這個轉折
如果等到了大盤就轉多
那當然不是每個人都在做大盤
那你就股票就同理可證
用同樣的方法去證明
你的股票就可以了
好 因為朱老師跟艾倫
對不對 都是看技術型態的
但因為我自己會去看基本面
市上台股基本面很好
例如說營收創新高
然後還有就是所謂的第二季季報
可能三律都三生也都創歷史新高
但是這樣的股票是不是一定可以買
可能要輔助於技術型態的檢驗
對
這就是我們講說
基本面好營收好各種利多消息的股票
會出現一大堆
絕對不會只有一檔
可是這麼多股票裡面
你要選到這個能夠會長的股票
那這個時候技術面就很重要
比如說我們來看一下
這個營收創新高的
也非常多
我來解釋一下這張表
這張表是融合了第二季的季報
跟七月營收
全部的項目通通創新高
就是很厲害的股票
就是台股在基本面上
無可挑剔的一群人
可是可以看到他們的股價
卻是一個撐赤不齊的狀態
會差很遠喔
有的還是空頭
對 那我們都講說
營收好也不是說
今天發布才知道營收好
應該在他前面
至少公司派知道
我這個月結算 營收會很好
可是很奇怪
他的股價還是會跌啊 對不對
所以他不是一個絕對的關係
不是說我營收好
我的股價就絕對漲
不是的
那可是我們做股票是在賺價差嘛
如果你不漲 你營收好對我沒用
你又不會把賺的錢給我
對不對
我要買到你股票
股票漲我才會賺到錢
所以我們要在這裡面
就要去過濾一下
哪些是真的有了營收
而且又有技術面
那這樣子我們做股票是不是
就比較容易賺到錢
就不會因為營收好就亂買
那你可能還會賠錢
好 這邊的話分散在各領域
像成熟製程 PC
這個很有名啊 聯電
大量這個很戲劇性
昨天漲停 今天跌跌
金居這好多人喜歡
齊鴻CPU的光聖聯亞
設備股的萬潤雅翔
記憶體的創建位要
都是指標類的股票
都是算是檯面上
大家都認得的股票 對不對
都知道這些股票
可是越是認得的越要小心
因為你很熟悉他嘛
那你一定會覺得他很好
比如像金居
大概沒有人不知道這支股票
因為他前一陣子實在太有名了
他就是長這樣缺掉
踢踩的第一棒
對不對
可是你看他跌下來不是跌混了
全部都給你跌掉一半以上
好 那我們最重要的說
大盤現在既然不跌了
是不是我們這些跌的股票
都可以買了
那我還有這個 還有營收啊
對啊
還是不一定
還有機報
對 所以我們還是要稍微的
去看一下
那我今天在這邊
最主要就給大家一個
很簡單的操作的一個邏輯
因為技術分析真的說起來
內容也是蠻多的啦
但是一般的觀眾
我用最簡單的方法
讓你能夠很快的
就抓到股票又能夠賺到錢
那這個方法其實就兩句話
第一個叫趨勢
第二個加轉折
所以你要先讓好趨勢
然後再去抓他的轉折
所以我如果大家習慣做多頭股票
所以這支股票一定要先多頭確認
好 要先確認
在這個確認之前
你都不要去買它
因為你是做多嘛
所以趨勢要多
好 那現在趨勢確認了
我就開始抓轉折
那這個是上漲下跌嘛
那我做多不可能做下跌嘛
所以你一定是坐在這裡嘛
下跌然後上漲嘛
沒錯
對不對
而且底不能破錢低嘛
我就講多頭趨勢
一定要維持 確認的
要維持
只要它在多頭的裡面
你在轉折的低點買
在轉折的高點賣
所以我這邊有一句話
你記下就好了
轉折向上買 是
突破盤折買 是
轉折向下賣
怎麼覺得我也會了
你會他
但你要圖打開我就不一定了
不是 大家其實比較
做錯就是因為
趨勢沒有把它辨別出來
你沒有看懂這個趨勢
只要你看懂它是多頭就這麼要
轉折向上買 轉折向下賣
就這賣 然後你要看農區式
這個不是多 它盤整
所以你後面就不能買了
如果你在盤子裡面轉折賣
那你就一巴來巴去
很容易雙巴
對 你就被巴那麼好
所以我當我區式看懂了
我的第二句話 突破盤整買
那我又等到你突破
所以突破盤整你買
那從那什麼時候賣
轉折向下賣
轉折向上賣
你只要這個沒有變
你就一直做一直做一直做
那他又進到盤整了
我還是賣掉了嘛
因為我轉折向下你要賣啊
所以你不會被套牢啊
哦 阿珠老師如果他沒有進入盤整
他只是多頭回答我不賣可以嗎
那就這個
那就是做長線
做長線
那我今天提供大家說
在短線上
你其實用這項子的觀念
你至少不會買錯
你不會買到高檔嘛
你一定買在轉折嘛
那你也知道在哪裡賣
也不會賣飛
因為你就轉折下來我才賣嘛
那就簡單的這個原則
我相信你對你做股票就有一個
有一個標準啊
好 有一個基本邏輯
對 基本的邏輯嘛
你不會亂買 你又不會亂賣
買在相對的低點
賣在相對的高點
你這樣子的先有了這個邏輯
反過來說
因為我們也有看到
觀眾朋友留言說
你們都在教人家做多
如果高檔下來怎麼不教做空呢
我就想說其實就圖反過來
應該就反過來
空頭的股票
他已經確認
空頭確認
底底低頭頭低
我現在開始你要做空
做空就反過來
再轉折向下賣
轉折向上補
我們空頭叫回補
轉折向下空
轉折向上補
然後還要不要向下空
盤整的時候先不要
就不要了嘛
因為它不是空頭
重點就是它不是空頭
然後這邊又跌破了
盤整跌破空
你就補空 補空
一直補到
又補到這個底底高了
那你又不做了
那你不做
如果它不下去了
它上來了你也不會做了
因為它轉成多頭了嘛
你就不會做
所以至少你不會做錯
不會做錯方向
不會做錯原則
這是最基本的嘛
你這樣子 剛剛我們的標
第一頁就講
你就不會被套牢啊
你只要按到做你就不會套牢
你是賺錢的
你不會賠錢的
只是你有時候運氣好
他一直跌 你就多賺一點嘛
尤其你做到後面
有可能就會極跌
那你這一段就賺了很多
所以我用這樣簡簡單的方法
你就像剛才趙發講
你又可以做多
你也可以做空啊
那只有一個不能做
就這個盤子
盤整區兩個都不要做
對 不管多空盤整都不要做
因為盤整我們不知道
未來是上去還是下來
這是市場來決定的
所以我們就等
如果是空樓 市場把它又跌破
那我們就繼續空
所以把握這兩個原則
我相信大家做股票就會比較輕鬆
沒有說這麼複雜 這麼藍
藍就是說你要把趨勢
先把它辨別出來
我覺得我已經記起來了
那觀眾朋友記起來了
因為接下來我們要混搭一些圖
好 那這些圖呢
都是剛剛講到的
起碾你說創新高
第二季機報創新高的好股票
那現在我們先來看大量
這個是他的波動很大
大量波動
那股票剛才我們講
我們列出來都是財報很好的
但是不一定圖很好
另外一個原則就是說
我現在要做多是不是
所以你一定是在做未來
你不會做到這一段多來嘛
那這一段都已經過了
也做不到
所以我們要做未來嘛
那未來我又不知道啊
所以你要用當下
這叫當下
就今天
今天收盤來判斷
這是股票到底是多還是空
今天跌停辦
跌停辦不一定是公投
還爆料
也不一定
都不一定
趨勢歸趨勢
成交量歸成交量
均線歸均線
你就是一個多頭股票
有時候均線還是空排
他不一定是多牌
好 那我們就看今天這根K線
是不是跌破5日均線
那是不是有個轉折了
跌破5日均算轉折
本來昨天早今天跌
那不就是轉折了嗎
那換句話講 如果你有買的
今天要賣
可是這橫盤都沒賺到錢
跌破5均就要先走
那我們現在先看他的趨勢
那這一年 這一出轉折
是不是這邊就有個高點
對
對你就有個高點
那上車的轉折在哪裡
是不是這個紅K站上來
這裡有個低點
對
觀眾應該看得到嘛
對不對
因為這個黑K是不是跌破五軍
紅K
然後黑K紅K是不是站上五軍了
所以這裡就有個低點
上車的轉折
低點在這裡
這一次的高點已經在這裡了
再來上車的高點是不是在這裡
對 因為它疊破了嘛
對 所以它上來 動又下來
所以這裡有個高疊
那低點呢 在這兒
好低
就最低嘛
對
好 那你先看這幾個點的關係是什麼
就是
這個頭 這個頭 這個底 這個底
是什麼
他講了
頭頭高低低高
他說多頭形態
這個頭頭高低低高啊
那既然是多頭
所以今天這個疊下來叫回檔
疊頂板 但它是回檔
你不要亂空 你不要以為說
哇 這麼弱的股票
他今天是多頭的回檔
那多頭回檔
我剛剛講多頭
那不是可以做多
那什麼時候做
明天大漲的話
轉折向上的時候買
轉折向上吧
轉折向上
你這個劇章就可以買了
那買了以後什麼時候賣
轉折向下你就賣
這樣對不對
那明天要漲多少才能賣呢
站上五軍
只要站上五軍都可以
這邊站上五群 這邊就有地點
那如果我在考一下主車
他針對我
ok吧 誰跟你說明天會炸
那今天碟地板大量明天會碟
對不對 以這個K線來講 明天是會碟的
這次講K線
那如果明天碟 後天又碟
有轉折向上了
對不對 這邊轉折向上
那這邊轉折向上
那請問這個人可不可以買
不行 為什麼
因為他一抵比一抵低
多頭不是轉折向上買
可是他已經打了一個抵
又比前面的抵低
因為他跌 沒錯
他跌負了這個低點
對啊 他變盤陣
你不能買的原因是
他不是多頭
是
我們第一個條件叫多頭
那不是多頭你又不能買
是
這樣就很清楚了
對不對
那如果在月線這裡的轉折呢
可以
對 它就是轉折向上來
下次轉折向下
轉折向下也有幾個變化
比如說我到了月線
前面低點沒破喔
我在這裡
終於真的來了
我在這裡買了
那什麼時候就是轉折向下賣
結果我在這裡轉折向下
那要不要賣
他過的前面的高不用賣
過的前面高更要賣
賺更多
兩個賣
轉折向下要賣
那賣了以後
這邊又轉折向上
底底高要不要賣
這無間地獄
無間考題
沒錯
你稍微打打
你技術分析就通
是
對吧
剛才我們的圖都有
因為我這個轉折向下
沒有過這個高點
所以這邊就不能買
因為它進到盤子
就像是盤子
你看技術分析
你未來的全部都規劃好了
請問這個股票
有什麼我不敢做
所以你不要怕
你往下我也知道
你往上我也知道
你不過高我也知道
我都有方法去做
這就是技術分析最好的地方
而且每個人都可以去規劃
那至於他怎麼走
我就不是我們決定的
如果我決定就這樣子
這就要最好 對不對
我先上車你在決定
就市場
他決定什麼我就做什麼
他走什麼就做什麼
所以這一支股票擺上來
再加上我們已經知道
壓接機好嘛
那只要我做多
我就放心做
為什麼可能有這樣
因為這哪有大量啊
大家不是很擔心
大量不過怎麼辦
那不過你就賣嘛
轉折向下你就賣嘛
你就不會有這麼多煩惱
對不對
考題一我已經背上都是漢文
考題二 光盛
光盛也是
我上課的學生都沒這樣考過
我就一直講
回去你聽得懂就懂
聽不懂就知道
所以觀眾有福了
今天一起參加考試
對
一樣這又是一個業績很好的
而且光盛本來就是一支
很好的股票
以前在CPU是領頭揚鑫的
這部比較弱
所以基本面沒有問題
但是基本沒有問題
如果你在這裡買你就完蛋
因為它是空頭
就很簡單 它就是空頭
你不要說空頭什麼的
大量紅蝦你就跑來買
空頭你做空鑽結
轉折下來空 上去補
下來空 上去補 下來空
上去補 你還是鑽結
我就一直跟大家講
你學會了 你就偷偷練一練
練完了你就有信心了
你下次就會自己做了
可是現在不是囉
因為我講我們做當下
當下來看
昨天黑K是跌下來
是不是有轉折
對嘛 那是不是有高點
有
所以高點這個很輕鬆
一看到了
這個是高點
那上次的低點呢
往前推那個月線上的黑K
黑K跌破了五軍
紅K站上
所以這裡有個低點
對
然後高點在這嘛
因為我講黑K跌破了嘛
所以上面有個高點
最低點當然一看大家都知道
這1000塊
整數好 剛好1000
剛好卡在1000塊
1000塊這是最低點
那我們看到今天
你看到的頭跟底是什麼
頭頭高 底底高
多頭型態
跟剛才是個一模一樣
現在如果你要做多頭
我要做多拉
那什麼時候做
不破錢低又上漲的時候
就轉折向上
轉折向上
然後又沒有破錢低
那後面的走勢
就跟剛才考試是一樣
如果跌破錢低
你就不要買了
或者你在月線上來
那沒有過高
你轉折向下 你要買
這樣子
你這支做多的股票就已經痛了
對不對
那如果他真的這樣一直走
走到那個3000塊2500
那你就一直做
你就一直做上去
那現在為什麼那麼多好機會
現在因為
前面這些好股票都跌得很深
當一個基本面好
然後財務也好
你本來就知道這些股票有價值了
這就叫有價值
那現在又有低價
那這個應該算是優先去把它選擇的
是
因為我們講跌的時候種植嘛
那些沒有基本面的
現在不一定會上來
因為跌的大家都嚇死了
都不敢去買了
但是這些有基本面
又有技術面的
是我們優先可以去選
不過像剛剛如果大萊根光射
現在都多頭型態
有沒有誰比較好的問題
對啊 有沒有誰比較好的比較
因為可能很多都長這樣
第一個我們講先要多頭
其實多頭你就可以做了
但你要加強說
我要做到更好的多頭
長得更快 是
速度更快 或是空間更大
對 那空間大就是看上面壓力
你的壓力還有成交量
那我現在這邊有量
我這個量已經過了 對不對
除非你又把它跌破了
那我這個量
你畫一條線
你就知道你大概會長到
是
好 畫到這邊
紅幫助老師接過來
幫助老師接過來
所以至少先攻到這
先攻到這
是 2000塊
2000元
對
剛好先一樣
那如果我在過程中再放量
那當然再去挑戰這個
2千3
是
這個就是你可以做比較
基本的規劃
那另外還有一個
因為我們大部分都是底部
鋼管完成多了
所以還有些你不要去做
就是均線還沒有做好
那這是為什麼那麼好
這是均線做好了
月線上揚
月線已經上揚了
月線是最基本的
只要你月線上揚
你就可以做了
那你如果從學會問
老師那個季線壓了怎麼辦
對
那你把剛才這個優望了
季線壓了
轉折向下你就賣
是
你就賣
你不會說
記線壓了我就一直賠一直賠啊
所以我們剛才那個原則就是
大家把它寄勞
所有的問題你都不要怕
只要你不要做錯方向
你不要說空樓去做多
這個麻煩了對不對
只要你是把趨勢加上轉折
你在股票市場
可以說是無往無利
好 聯電
聯電也是大家你看前面怎麼漲的
大家暴雨後望
想說這下要兩百三百了
那一樣大盤不好他就回來了
可是他財報還是很好啊
還是很好 上新高
所以大家就會懷疑
那為什麼會跌那麼多呢
對不對
財報就像財機店
這個業績
他不要跌那麼多
可是股票本來就不是
我們可以自己去想的
我們完全根據他
那我們就來看這支股票
他就不一樣了
這是我票不是昨天
前三天就跌破五軍
所以他前天一跌破五軍
你的高點就出來了 對不對
這個黑黑跌破嘛
高點就出來了嘛
那前面的低點在哪裡
紅黑站上嘛 對不對
所以這是不是低點
是
那他跌破這個站上
這個黑黑所以這裡是高跌
那這裡是低跌
對不對
對
那這個這個是頭頭高
這個是底底高
這是多頭
但是今天呢
我們把它看一下
因為很接近這個價格
沒有啦
今天已經把這個底點跌破了
他把它跌破了
所以今天他就不是多頭了
所以這支股票你就不能說
轉折向上來買
因為他不是多頭了
叫嗎
還有一個就我剛剛講的
這個月線還很糟糕
下彎的很厲害
還在壓
所以你就
就算他這個很好
請你擺在後面去
因為我們剛才那兩隻已經很棒了
那兩隻比較好
對啊 你就說了嘛
就是我們講說
剛才趙豪問的
那到底要做哪一隻啊
哪個比較好啊
哪個比較強啊
那聯電你就暫時不要去做他
因為剛才那一隻也是100多嘛
那這也是100多嘛
好 剛剛那隻是1000多老師
沒有 還有一隻100多吧
好 兩隻都比較高價
兩隻都很高價
好嘛 那你就等這一隻
大家為什麼散戶朋友特別獨一的價格
比較親密 對
你就等他
等他符合我們的條件
好 那我們還是一樣再來看
亞翔
我們設備股的那個龍頭
亞翔當然我們一看就知道
因為這邊都一路往下嘛
對不對
這個頭啊 頭啊 頭啊
越來越迫低
可是所以我們現在就剛剛講
這是最低點
那這個黑黑跌下來
這是高跌
那現在跌下來還沒有上去啊
對
那它前面的高點在哪
在這啊 對
對不對 這個跌下來嘛
所以它還在頭頭低啊
那這個低點的前面在這啊
這叫底底底
所以它叫空頭的彈後空下跌
它還完全沒有做成多頭
沒有 沒有 它是空頭
那你做空不是跌下來做空嗎
所以你其實在這裡做空
是
來 你做空這幾天也是賺錢了耶
也賺錢
我捨不得空壓箱
對不起 我感情
而且他月線還在向下
對不對
那如果他繼續空
有可能還要這個底
不過這個股票
大概你不會空到太多了
因為這個底就是一個微星反轉
而且這邊有大量
所以大家就要注意喔
你如果做空要什麼時候補
轉折的時候補
轉折向上
回答得很心虛
你為什麼不說
轉折向補啦
那你如果轉折向上補
你沒有賠錢
那有什麼好害怕的
我只要一上上我就補
我又不用有賠錢
我沒這個問題
因為我不會空牙箱
然後你補了以後
假設在這裡
從這裡到這裡賺錢
然後它又疊了
叫不會空
可以
為什麼
因為他還沒有做好多頭啊
你轉著一上這個就要叫底底高啊
兩個底做好了
他進盤整
他進到盤整去
所以你就等一等
這次盤整有可能就變多啦
考試不通
你後面再變多
好不好
所以我們今天就用
簡單的這幾個邏輯
大家至少拉出一支股票
你就按照這樣去
比手畫腳
你就知道可以做還是不能做
我們散戶就只要知道這個就可以了
我知道可以做知道不能做
你就可以避開很多的風險
我今天只有一個慶幸
就是這個螢幕是有邊框的
所以畫到後面
我不用再回答了
對 但是我今天很遺憾
是我的小老師都沒有要幫我的
我就認真看
所以今天也很謝謝朱老師
每一次朱老師都想得簡潔易懂
可是等到看到圖的時候
我們就會產生猶豫了
因為很久以前我就上過做老師的課
可以說繼續看
所以今天我們花了一點時間
其實是簡單的口訣
不管做多或做空
搭配圖大家回家練習一下
對
好